[Applause]
everybody welcome an education I'm Kevin
Smith and I'm anemic alpha Hey
all right man we got a healthy [ __ ]
quiz ahead of us Andy has spent all this
time this week every free moment coming
up with questions that ask y'all and we
have a bunch of goofy prizes to give out
but before we do anything I just want to
point out six months ago is the night I
almost died
yeah so it's nice to be here man I can
live through that [ __ ]
all right live through it so I could do
the pub quiz right here with you all
Andy came up with a bunch of questions
we got a bunch of prizes round one of
course is the Terry Fox around Terry Fox
prep round where you will be playing for
three Terry Fox prep uniforms from the
movie yoga hosers ladies and gentlemen
the Terry Fox Terry Fox round is always
high school themed it is Andy has come
up with some dandies for us today
explain this category well this week
we're gonna do high school love
triangles famous television high school
love triangles and we're gonna give it
two names of each of the characters in
the triangle and you have to tell us the
name of the show oh okay now I get it
I'm looking at it going what all right
here we go
everyone put your phones down get your
pens up get your cards at the ready and
here we go we're about to begin
the edge of the edge of a pop quiz put
your hands together give us your energy
so we start right here we go number one
in the Terry Fox Brown I'm gonna give
you three names you tell me the show the
show or movie the show show here we go
number one Dylan Kelly Brenda come on
you'd have to be born yesterday to not
get that one number two Spencer
Caleb Hanna I'm out this one I know you
know it you must you know mall you
didn't watch the light TV with your girl
did you
and denies and every time it rings
number three
hide Jackie and Kelso I think I know
that one number four Nate Blair and
Chuck Nate Blair and Chuck love triangle
over and then the fifth and final clue
in the Terry Fox round Rachel Finn and
Quinn
there you go there Rachel Finn and Quinn
familiar names I know they're on the tip
of your tongue the Terry Fox round is
almost at an end man if you're done
filling out your card hold it up Nate or
Big Daddy Jimmy V will collect it go
tabulate it in the back those questions
once again number one Dylan Kelly and
Brenda number two Spencer Caleb and
Hanna
number three hi Jackie and Kelso number
four Nate Blair and Chuck and number
five Rachel Finn and Quinn man you got
all the cards my friend
cards up folks throw your heads up wave
them like you just don't care given the
one of these five books Nate I heard
somebody calling you over here hey on
your name in the night
we're countdown the end of this round
ladies gentlemen five four three two one
[ __ ] that round it's over we did it oh
we got another uh-oh they're in well I
got some [ __ ] teams they're all in
this one all right here we go let us do
the answers man you got your answer key
professor I have the answer key not a
real professor here we go
Dylan Kelly and Brenda Andy why that
would be Beverly Hills 90210 so
literally man
number two this through me Spencer Caleb
and Hanna so I watched many years with
my daughter pretty little liars pretty
little lies these big fans over here I
didn't watch this show but I think hide
Jackie and Kelso refer to that 7e show
that 70s show for number three that 70s
show number four was Nate Blair and
Chuck so this might be a harder for some
of you guys it was Gossip Girl
oh she lip synched with my yes somebody
got it and then number five
Rachel Finn and Quinn and that would be
the high school show Glee all right well
duh man those are tough how many winters
why there's only one team that managed
to get four correct holy [ __ ] who is
that winning team is gonna walk away or
Terry Fox Prep [ __ ] t-shirt and and
short sets Andy let me be the first to
congratulate you know matrix 0.01
you know matrix sent a representative up
here we are gifting you with actual worn
costumes from a movie nobody saw
congratulations give it up for our lace
gym man they won around - ladies and
gentlemen is the tease me round and the
tease me around the prize that we like
to give away our old t-shirts of mine
that I no longer fit into anymore
you got a couple three and 4x t-shirts
right here one is Felix the Cat which I
used to wear the [ __ ] out of when I got
laid this one is the dude and this one
is the sinister six all worn by me all
got my DNA all over a man [ __ ] some of
them probably use to come rag at one
point so you're walking away with
potentially being able to build the next
Kevin Smith or just go right get some
tag with bleach after this that's true
tide pot will take care of that okay
round 2 teas me the category always has
something to do with teas and this week
Andy as a humdinger for you man the tea
in question Teen Titans
yes that's right everyone's got a
fighting chance in this bar here we go
man it falls down pens up get your cards
ready and the first question in round 2
is what is beast boy's real name and
don't say changeling what is beast boy's
real name will you accept 1 or first
name last name but if you if you get one
or the other and we have a run off it'll
be fine number two in the teen titans
comic book what is the name of the
Titans fictional city fictional city
referred to on the show only not my name
I don't know I think I think I do if
it's from the comics where do villains
and training go to school it's at the
cartoon villains and training famous
school where do the Titans villains in
training to go to school number four who
sings the Teen Titans theme song Teen
Titans that one that one if you're a
Cartoon Network fan you'll know this one
and number five the last question in
this round ladies and gentlemen what
superhero group included Mentos
Elastigirl negative man and robot man I
know this yes and Elastigirl not just an
incredible also in the teen titans
that's right originally before a way
before there a negative man not just you
a character in Teen Titans I'm positive
man ultra buzzer there it is folks the
end of round two if you've finished
filling out your cards hold those cards
and yes sir Big Daddy Jimmy V or Nate
will come pick them up from you man
they'll tabulate them all done Nate we
got a card over here Nate there's a car
here blowing in the wind right there
there we are and we're gonna end this
round and link cards come in seven
seconds seven six five four three two
one [ __ ] that round is over ladies
gentlemen round Tuesday
in the books all right Andy take us
there man
what is beast boy's real name beast
boy's real name is Garfield Logan would
you have accepted gar I would have taken
gar Garfield gl hyah spoke to him on an
animated film the Judas contract I was
on his podcast where was he on mine some
I think he was on mine okay I'm it was
kind of sweet but I loved the Judas
contract when I was growing up there was
no podcasting character in it so I felt
like it was kind of my fault that it
wasn't close to the book the old me
would have been so mad that they present
me was in that cartoon like he wasn't in
the [ __ ] book and [ __ ] wanted to
write a letter to DC and be like [ __ ]
Kevin Smith love Kevin Smith here we go
number two in the teen titans comic book
what is the name of titans fictional
city jump city jump city we got some
jump city fans over there jump city
number three where do the villains and
training go to school Andy the hive
Academy HIV stands for hierarchy of
international vengeance and
extermination we would also have taken
HAF e YP because that is the sort of
grad school for hive Academy but hive
Academy is the answer
[ __ ] egg number four who sings the
Teen Titans theme song puffy AmiYumi
yeah yes got their own show on Cartoon
Network
what puffy I'm happy immunity and number
five what superhero group included
Mentos Elastigirl negative man and robot
man that can only be the Doom Patrol
that Doom Patrol Patrol there it is man
one winner in this round one winner with
five all the way a perfect five correct
answers walking away with the out of the
shirts it's got to be the French
ticklers the French ticklers gentlemen
pleasure man pleasure Wehrman good
health and they they won that round for
her pleasure ah
okay man we're in round three ladies and
gentlemen the round one and two are in
our rearview round three is about to
happen this is the brats around man in
this round you have an opportunity to
win a one or in this case two of a kind
movie prop man there's one full bra see
right here yes it's a kit this is build
your own bronzy damn right you have to
put it together this came from a movie
called yoga hosers and you could walk
away from it with walk away don't walk
away from it we're walking away from it
you can walk away with it if you answer
these five questions pertaining to our
subject which is monsters you ready to
go man put your phones down get your
pens up get your card ready god bless
you here we go what is the name of the
town and state that is menaced by
Pennywise the clown
Pennywise the clown recently he had his
own film some color commentary yes
Pennywise recently terrorized a bunch of
children on the big screen I don't
remember the name of it can't remember
it number two what actors character was
first to die in alien wait for it
covenant oh we all felt an alien
covenant what a [ __ ] nut biter that
well it was a bit of a trudge it really
is hard but there was a screen death at
the beginning that was very famous
number three who co-wrote cabin in the
woods with director Drew Goddard cabin
in the woods famous puzzle box mystery
famous writer wrote that script with
with the director with the daughter who
went on to do daredevil that is correct
and didn't he do the Martian as well he
wrote the script for the Martian I you
know you're beyond me on that one he did
thank you
number four what are the show Bachan
show vision from the first mafra movie
in the Mothra movie the first ones that
what they're called
there was the show begin and you must
identify what they are
tennis I'm rephrasing the question
almost with no more information Mothra
appears in the trailer for next summer's
Godzilla king of the monsters
yeah okay wait so the gamourai think I
saw a gamma in the trailer as well
number four no that was number four
number five what kind of candy bar does
Professor Bruton home give Hellboy near
the start of the film Hellboy miles over
there Hellboy what kind of candy bar
does the professor give Hellboy near the
start of the film
Hellboy ladies and gentlemen that is the
last question in this round if you fill
out your card you got all your answers
throw them up and Nate will trot over
and collect it from your Big Daddy Jimmy
B's doing it on this side I have a
question for you answer at what point
will hell boy changed his name to hell
adult I just don't get Helmand Helmand
he's like bring out the ho man and bring
out the bass refreshing there it is
folks
you got your cards done hold them up
where you countdown the end of this
round five four three two one monsters
is over man put your hands together we
did it we accomplished something all
right Andy take us there man thank you
take us there what's the name of the
town and state menace by Pennywise the
clown that would be Derry Maine Derry
Maine Derry Maine indeed not Castle Rock
you're right yes you're like yes I am
Virginia what actors character was the
first to die in alien covenant James
Franco died first in that movie James
Franco was that because I got the answer
writer because James Franco died little
taste of each what actor or know who
code who co-wrote cabin in the woods
with director Drew Goddard as yaw Sweden
Joss Whedon
Joss Whedon and Drew Goddard famously
wrote that script in three days really
yes and there they were both Buffy kids
right they were number four what are the
show Bachan from the first moth for a
movie why those are the little twins
miniature fairy people so we would take
mini girls or twins or fairies would be
fine too little women in shell which did
guess we bled I believe that's how they
were listed in the credits
two little women in show number five
what kind of candy bar does the
professor give Hellboy near the start of
the film he was a hell baby so he got a
help Baby Ruth Baby Ruth fire alright on
man that was a tough around the alien
covenant question would have killed me
for sure but we got a winner
killed didn't kill somebody he defecates
Franco is that a complete card no this
is a well they did not sweep weight they
did sweep they got dairy correct oh not
the same right but we'll take it either
way they won with they did one with four
correct answers and that would be the
French ticklers lady gentleman of theirs
come and get your brats see well Wow
well done you guys are mopping the floor
with a French tickler you guys know so
much here we go number four round four
ladies and gentlemen the raw round in
the raw round you get to walk away if
you win with this complete smoking kit
man there's a tray and there's a bunch
of rolling papers and stuff there's a
little mini pocket ashtray and there's a
doob tube so if you've never smoked weed
there get started it's everything you
need except the weed right and if you do
smoke weed look at this [ __ ] man you
won't have to go to the store for a
little bit it's got everything except
for artist artificial chemicals or
preservatives that's right man it's pink
hearts yellow moons orange stars and all
that good [ __ ] round for the raw round
always predicated on famous stoners not
famous donors this is I'm sorry that
that's from last week this is just
general questions about about marijuana
that's a
type out there oh so just all right so
this is weed yeah all right questions
about weed here we go
number one put your phones down get your
pens up goddammit number one what does
THC stand for whoo and truth justice in
American Way is not the answer number
two what version of cannabis is the root
of the word assassin the word cannabis
gives us the word assassin somehow is
that right did you just find that out
recently the question is what version of
cannabis is the root of the word
assassin yes there's a version of
cannabis it's in the education book
number three Ziggy Marley debuted his
pop superhero at 2011's WonderCon what
was the character's name Ziggy Marley
coming up with a pot themed superhero
and announcing it at 2011's WonderCon
what was his name what was the name of
the character Lori petti played what pot
smoking comic book character in a 1995
movie Lori Petty's finest hour ladies
and gentleman possibly only our Point
Break and should model Laurie cutting
love anchor guys don't be petty about
Lori petty here we go number five what
kind of animal is used to attack the
dude when he's smoking a joint in the
tub in the Big Lebowski what animal is
weaponized death the dude when he's in
the tub in the Big Lebowski man when you
write the answer to that down hold up
your card ladies and gentlemen one of
our two fine man servants over here Big
Daddy Jimmy V or Nate will collect your
cards take them in the back tabulate the
[ __ ] out of them any cards and let you
know who the winner of
that rounds gonna be you're all winners
in our hearts but only one person could
walk away with the raw tray man full raw
smoking kit yes all cards collected one
one one more countin down slow five
seconds to the end around five four
three two one
we're done ladies Jim put your hands
together we accomplished something all
right man the level of difficulty in
that round jumped all around
let's go to number one what does THC
stand for you know I put so much this
into my body and I have no idea what
does it stand for it says for
tetrahydrocannabinol that's the name of
the molecule so there's four hydrated
parts onto the can of an olive root
tetrahydrocannabinol
tetrahydrocannabinol kind of banal
number two what version of cannabis is
the root of the word assassin hashish
hashish the assassins were paid in
hashish and that's where we get the word
assassin get out of here really [ __ ]
a nice hash guy hash guy yeah I guess we
tagged him with him so we technically be
a hashtag hashtag
number three Ziggy Marley debuted his
pot superhero at the 2011 WonderCon what
was the character's name Andy the very
cleverly named marijuana man marijuana
man they sent us materials at the
tonight show to try to promote it how
long is he working on that when it wraps
draft I believe they wrote famously he
came up with it in three nights
number four Lori petti played what pot
smoking comic book character in a 1995
movie why that would be Tank Girl hey
girl gentlemen and then number five what
kind of animal is used to attack the
dude when he's smoking a joint in the
tub and The Big Lebowski Andy give it to
him well the dude says nice marmot but
it's actually a ferret ferret is the
correct answer so we were looking for
ferret we're looking for a ferret
once again the card is up and once again
there's only one winner so far no no
dual winner
in these rounds you know hey Soph that's
interesting man who Andy is walking away
with this raw round raw smokin kid from
the good folks at raw it's three wookies
walk into a bar congratulations three
wookie cookies send a representative up
here and get your booty well done sir
excellent all right man
that's round four that means we're on to
round five ladies and gentlemen this
round is named that's the titular round
named in honor of the book and the
podcast that lets us gather in the first
place this is the education round and if
you win you're gonna win this copy of
education which if you don't win you
could find on Amazon is that correct
that is correct it's on Amazon or in
your local book store all of these
answers have to do with or came from the
education book and or podcast they come
from the book or podcast and there's a
few extra facts thrown in there so
people don't get tired of the same old
same old
here we go man number one put your
phones down get your pens up folks here
we go number one the Krampus is a
combination of part man and part what
other animal need a pen you got a pen we
gotta sign this I have no penny Oh
anybody got a Sharpie or pen back there
I got it number two what animal derives
from the ancient Greek for camel Sparrow
camels Pharaoh you ever do that you go
to a wedding get your picture taking
you're like oh my god I've got candles
Pharaoh happens to me all the time
you take that I'm also going to sign in
the book because sometimes people can't
see that books defeating me could you
hold it there yeah that [ __ ] totally
legible and [ __ ] take that second grade
teacher number three the Deaf adder is
native to what country what country is
home to the famous poisonous snake the
death
ma'am in the minimun - ma'am and a
minister named for adding up a lot of
deaths no way that's not what matters
name four number four
mermaids are commonly believed to be
what creature as seen through the eyes
of a horny sailor ten months at sea and
they're like that could be a behalf
woman half sea creature if I could
squint and then number five
Ian Fleming took James Bond's name from
the author of what kind of books
Ian Fleming took the name James Bond
from the author of what kind of books
lifelong passion of Ian Fleming's and
that's where he got the name for James
Bond that's where he got the name for
James Bond from the author and the
author of a certain kind of book yeah
there you go folks five five questions
you got to provide the five answers in
round five the education round the
winner of this round is going to walk
away with a signed copy of Andy's book
education signed by both Andy and me
it's all in there it's those parts are
right in there it's a perfect book to
keep in the bathroom right next yes a
[ __ ] no you do it on the back on the
commode you put it behind the [ __ ]
throw your hands up throw your cards up
Big Daddy Jimmy being Nate gonna collect
them and stuff and once they do that are
they all done yeah I'm down the end of
the round five four three two one we did
it we're halfway done ladies and
gentlemen all right take us there
captain the Krampus is a combination of
part man and what other animal a goat
he's a very satanic and but we would
have also taken RAM because in some
countries they say he's half RAM fair
enough number two what animal derives
from the ancient Greek for camel Sparrow
you love them and dude where's my car
it's ostriches the ostrich is the camel
Sparrow and it makes sense when you
think about it
now I think it's just adorable you
invoke dude where's my car it's been a
minute
the Death Adder is native to what
country Andy it's the country that just
wants to kill you Australia home of the
death number for mermaids are commonly
believed to be what creature has seen
through the eyes of a horny sailors this
a manatee a manatee we would take sea
cow or dugong as well what's the last
last Madhu gone do Gus it's another name
for a sea cow a sea
oh the huge manatee number five
Ian Fleming to James Bond's name from
the author of what kind of books bird
guides are bird-watching books Ian
Fleming was a huge bird enthusiasts team
you like his birds yes goldeneye is the
name of a bird yes that's what he named
his estate after and that movie so there
it is man five questions we're asked
five answers were given and I see more
than one card on the bar that means
we're gonna have a runoff
we heard the education book man so take
us there captain whoo we need a
representative from the following three
teams it would be the French ticklers
French ticklers done somebody up here
old man Brody old man Brody send
somebody up here and three wookies walk
into a bar wookies send somebody up here
man we're all gonna play for the book
how are you congratulations captain
congratulations captain congratulations
captain what we're gonna do is put our
hands over the bar like this question
will be asked first hand to hit the bar
we go to that person if they get it
wrong we go to the next person to hit
the bar here we go you got a mic ready
for these cats education round
edumacation what do you call it runoff
round this is the runoff ask him a
question I'm washing their hands what
are the four chambers of education four
chambers of education you can't look in
the book oh yes
could see how what a beloved podcast
that education is yes alright here we go
ask a second well the answer to that was
of course the sci-fi the why and the bye
and you should listen to the podcast
sometime be good don't scold the father
right in front of us no I was
encouraging all right the Indian Cobra
is native to what country that's correct
holy [ __ ] give it up you wanna copy of
Education he's the winner good
congratulations
listen left you hanging left me after
last week's jaws round I had to make it
a little easier
remember the jaws around last week it
was tough this did you take mine and I
took yours
I don't think so here we go so this is
it genre gems here we go round six
ladies and gentlemen just wanna make
sure it was in last week's or something
round six ladies gentlemen genre gems
round this is where Andy goes deep on
any number of particular genres this
week the genre is buddy movie and since
its genre gems what you're gonna win in
this round is this amazing Batman statue
look at that that's the Chris Nolan
Batman stature it's got interchangeable
hands so you could put the big-ass gun
in nice hands as well so look at that
man we're playing for keeps right here
this is out of my office for a long time
I don't want it anymore
yours here we go it's not broken
genres gems question number one in Hot
Fuzz what buddy movie does Nick Frost
character reenact by shooting his gun
awesome great question fully approved
number two what was the first animated
movie directed by 21 jump street phil
lord and chris miller so they made that
famous buddy cop movie 21 Jump Street
but they directed an animated movie
before that oh yeah before that
or I don't know if it was before was it
before what was their first animated
movie that was question yes okay what
was the first animated movie directed by
Phil Lord and Chris Miller number three
who played the super cop buddy team who
die and are replaced by Will Ferrell and
Mark Wahlberg in the other guy's famous
bunny comedy movie there were two super
cops and they both leap to their deaths
number four before making the heat what
was sandy Bullock's last law enforcement
comedy I think I know this one before
she made the heat man what was the last
law enforcement comedy Sandra Bullock
was in and then number five last
question this round folks how many rush
hour movies are there and why
[Laughter]
how many rush hour movies are there what
is the sub question does it include what
does it include upcoming know how many
R's are there not will there be there it
is you can't look into a nightmare
future like that well we no one's coming
the end of the round folks round six
we've asked five questions we're looking
for five answers one you fill in your
cards hold them up Nate or Big Daddy
Jimmy V are gonna grab them from you and
right now we're gonna count down the end
of the round we're gonna give it a ten
count ten nine eight seven six five four
three two one that rounds over ladies
jump put your hands together we
accomplished something together together
strong here we go man genre gems if you
will and Andy asked five questions and
Andy's gonna give you five answers in
Hot Fuzz what buddy movie does Nick
Frost character reenact by shooting his
gun Point Break Point Break my break
what was the first animated movie
directed by Phil Lord and Chris Miller
that be the lego movie Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs
oh you're right you know and we have a
connection our friend who did who was
the effects supervisor for that he made
the sauerkraut in that movie and he made
it in yoga Hooters days then that movie
did very well and we did not it was
obviously not the sauerkraut yeah a
truly number three who played the super
cop buddy team who died and are replaced
by Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg in the
other guys that would we'd Wayne the
rock Johnson and samuel l.jackson yes
number four before making the heat what
was Sandra Bullock's last law
enforcement comedy Miss Congeniality two
armed and fabulous
nice-nice can't shout armed and fabulous
with that kind of anger and then number
five how many rush hour movies were
there are there how many rush our movies
are three rush hour movies uh and it
there was a TV show right all right we
got how many winners there's two looks
like we're gonna have a runoff let's
have a representative from the following
teams ladies and gentlemen go Andy
bantha fodder and three wookies walk
into a bar rookie send somebody up here
this is a counter slapper or is this a
face-off get between them when you can
juicy up a bang okay
this is this is the round where Andy's
gonna give you a subject and you guys
basically just have to go back and forth
you got three seconds to come up with an
answer
yeah you ready yes we'll start with you
you ready movies that have spaceships in
them Star Wars a new hope
Star Trek Empire Strikes Back man oh man
what a bummer but he won't give it up
armless Joe
it's a hard game well done though take
your Batman and go chanting well done
that's what happens man sometimes just
fries and show you like Fox spaceships
all right round seven ladies and
gentlemen we're off to round seven round
seven is the Smithsonian Museum this is
around that's about me Kevin Smith and
the prize what you're gonna win this
week is an old pair of SModcast speakers
that's right they are size 9 and 1/2
etnies made them back in the day I've
signed them as well I wore the [ __ ] out
of him there were actually a pair of
sneakers made for a podcast I think we
were the first one the winner of this
round is gonna walk away with those got
my DNA all over it [ __ ] suitable for
suitable for bronzing and hanging from
the rearview mirror absolutely or just
flat-out wearing Smithsonian Museum is
the category pens up phones down here
you go folks number one according to the
IMDB what word is said 248 times in Jay
and Silent Bob strike back one word in
particulars seems low number two
Howard sure composer of the Lord of the
Rings trilogy score did the music for
which Kevin Smith film yeah it's a
really good score and then he borrowed
from it for Lord of the Rings as well as
Tarantino I mean you can't blame him
right
he's like nobody heard this number of
free what is Tracy Morgan's character's
name in Jay and Silent Bob strike back
most adorable yes number four is in
Jersey girl
Gertie performs a song from what musical
I would be winning the hell out of this
cat is I know them all I really wrote
them for you thanks
if you go walk down memory lane and then
number five according to IMDB a scene
between Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez
was cut before the movie came out what
happens in that cutscene according to
IMDB there was a scene in Jersey girl
between Affleck and Lopez that was cut
before the movie came out what happens
in that scene when you've written that
answer down that means your card is
complete
that means Big Daddy Jimmy V or Nate are
gonna pick up your cards they're gonna
take them in the front which we call the
back and they're gonna tabulate them
we're gonna figure out who is superior
who reigns supreme in this room full of
big brains that's right the a-team has
showed up today
absolutely when what that's not up to me
that's up to the folks at new Miramax
right they've got it all we gave them
all the materials for the long cut of
Jersey girl and they were working on it
and then it just kind of like we haven't
heard anything about it since so sooner
or later I'm sure it'll happen me too
man be nice for people to see the long
coat some people are terrified though
they're like what there's [ __ ] more
like I just say years ago my favorite
part is that guys standing in the video
in the video store with his back to Liv
Tyler she runs by OBU that was big Andy
has a very brief cameo in Jersey girl
here we go did we collect the cards
everybody in counting the round down 5 4
3 2 1 [ __ ] you that rounds over put your
hands together here we go folks number
one I better get all these right
Courtney IMDB what word is said 248
times in Jay and Silent Bob strike back
why that word would be [ __ ] that is
correct
[ __ ] number 2 I didn't invent the word
but I sure used the [ __ ] out of it
number 2 Howard Shore composer of the
Lord of the Rings trilogy score did the
score for what Kevin Smith film that
would be my fourth film Dogma that is
correct Sarah did a great job is
wonderful score number three that we
recorded it at Abbey Road
by the well man that want number three
what is tracy morgan's character's name
in Jay and Silent Bob strike back that
would be pumpkin Escobar pumpkin ESCO
bumpkin Escobar he came up with that
name himself you call myself pumpkin
Escobar that's a good number three or
four in Jersey girl gertie performs a
song from what musical Sweeney Todd wait
I they built the whole shootin match and
we beat Tim Burton to the screen by like
two three years I think yeah but his
movie had waited a lot more money and
then number five according to the IMDB a
scene between Affleck and Lopez was cut
before the movie came out what happens
in the scene I'm gonna say they danced
together they got married according to
the and Affleck and Lopez split before
the movie came out and so the movie
makers decided to remove that from the
IMDB says but in real life that got cut
way too [ __ ] earlier before they even
broke up instead okay but good to know
but yeah there's footage of that a
wedding that never happened yeah I
remember we had to do it super-secret
and hide them and [ __ ] there it is folks
we got all the answers we got a couple
cards of three cards three [ __ ]
winner is gonna be contending for the
dirty pair of sneakers the speakers from
etnies man they say have a weak on the
back of them I've signed the side of
them
Scott's faces inside my face is inside
the other one tell us we want one
representative from each of the
following teams go Andy
the first team is bantha fodder man
you're playing for the shoes of course
we're gonna feel this one again it's the
French ticklers French tickler no French
they've got it covered
and finally stoners strike back and they
got the wedding question correct they
got the which one the wedding a wedding
question [ __ ] nice come on
how are you sir okay here we go man
we're putting our hands over the counter
and we're listening for the question and
he's gonna give us right now first one
to hit the counter if you get the answer
right you walk away with the shoes if
not then we gotta go move on down you
get eliminated here we go what is the
name of the podcast Kevin Smith does
with Ralph Garman oh you win man take
them shoes you want give it up a sack
well done you haven't you don't
understand Kevin until you've walked a
mile in his shoes and now you have a
chance to yeah it's true do anything you
want in them shoes man
okay number eight round eight ladies and
gentlemen round eight is the Kessel run
all these questions have to do with Star
Wars man so you gotta know a little
something about Star Wars put your
phones down get your pens up get your
cards out cuz here we go we're about to
take the Kessel run and Jaycee are you
in here oh there you are okay
prize for the Kessel run ladies and
gentlemen one of two things both
actually these are Jay and Silent Bob
strike back mini mates from the good
folks at diamond and I will sign those
for you and this is a vintage as Empire
Strikes Back bold man looks just like
the one that I used to eat out of his
kid I bought two you can have [ __ ]
one of them right there just like the
movies were serialized he deserves it
all right man we all ready to make the
Kessel run with us ladies and gentlemen
put your hands together if you're ready
to make the Kessel run here we go number
one according to the original toy box
what does at-at stand for I know it's
with justice in American Way is the
answer what does that stand for from the
original toy box Kenner Kenner built my
childhood number two what planet are
wookies from and then Andy like a [ __ ]
wrote spelling counts
that's the best of cruel [ __ ] right
there
it totally I'll take phonetically
spelled correctly also very important to
spell this one right number three the
actor who played Zod in the Christopher
Reeve Superman movie plays what
character in Episode one yeah it's a
tough one man
only JC got that one whoever sit next to
JC's happened I don't think the actor
that plays out of the crew he's got that
one yeah he would have been like I was
in that movie number four what is Leia's
adopted mother's name that one hurt
stuff and then finally to complete the
castle round question five who killed
Kit Fisto who killed Kit Fisto that's
right we asked who ooh
[Music]
JC you knows killed there it is folks
the five questions that make up the
Kessel run are done that means you've
filled out your card and you hold it up
Nader Big Daddy Jimmy V will collect
them and then we will go tabulate and
see who's the fastest who actually made
the Kessel run man those are a mixed bag
of questions remember heart two of them
are really hard but the opening question
is a was designed for 70s kids yeah you
know this it's in your blood is one of
those terms that you just memorize you
know it like you know your social
security number the rounds at an end
folks are gonna give you five seconds to
hand in the rest of your cards five four
three two one
oh it's all [ __ ] over put your hands
together we finished that guys I'll run
together okay Annie according to the
original toy box what does that stand
for I'll take this one
yes all-terrain armored transport that
is correct all terrain armored transport
number two
what planet are wookies from cheek but
how do you spell it
ka Sh why why why k wow it looks like a
zipper number three the actor who plays
odd in Superman 2 and Superman 1 he
plays what character in episode 1 that
would be the Chancellor Chancellor finis
valorum malorum that's it would you have
just taken Chancellor we heard some
rumor you know I did the movie premiere
for MTV for episode 1 dude and we talked
to the producers and we heard some funny
rumors and one was that he playing that
role there was only green screen and a
folding chair so he just got really
hammered and they had to build a CG
version of him to actually finish it all
right now number four what is princess
Leia's
adoptive mother's name that would be
queen Abraha Organa wow I didn't know
that you know that I hunt Organa I would
have just said mrs. Organa
queen organic wheat Organa let's take
Queen Organa Queen Organa would come
yeah it sounds like a trick question and
then number five who killed Kit Fisto JC
is it Jango Fett no I'm sorry
it was Chancellor Palpatine Wow he was
the third to die in that little hint
that fight they had oh that's right up
in the room he goes after the three yeah
from the council does Darth Sidious
count as a respite yeah okay he wasn't
in his Darth Sidious form at the time
but everybody's I'd say Darth Sidious
counts okay
did we Jimmy do we have any others that
had Darth Sidious that would give us two
very good so how many winners open
actually that would give us three so
that would be the only winner of the
round and it would be
Rickie's walk into a bar the winners
three wookies sent a representative up
there what happened well because of the
right answer yeah you did it man nicely
done you did you fought for it you wanna
give it up for me walks away with some
[ __ ]
all right folks here we go round nine
man round nine is the Funko pop popped
me in the mouth round man pop culture
questions abound and the winner of this
round is gonna walk away with a signed
Kevin Smith pop see that bad boy comes
from Jan's silly Bob's secret stash and
know what I'd Bank New Jersey man here
we go put your phones down get your pens
up get your cards ready question number
one what rock legend demanded Trump stop
playing his music at rallies this week
this week is being the active ingredient
yes there been a few but this happened
this week number two what American
actress recently withdrew from the UK's
Celebrity Big Brother I know this as
well what American actress recently
withdrew from the UK's so the TV show
Celebrity Big Brother is American
actress on the show she's out number
three which Kardashian slash Jenner
celebrated a birthday with a Barbie
themed party this week yes that question
is designed to make you vomit which
kardashian-jenner celebrated a birthday
with a Barbie themed party this week
that one I don't know and I'm happy to
say congratulations number four beyonce
is on the latest cover of Vogue wearing
what on her head a goose it's not the
Bjork it's Beyonce and number five they
added a new Oscar category recently what
is it a new Oscar category why that's
huge news in the pop culture world yes
what are they gonna call this new Oscar
category constellation there it is man
the Funko pop culture question round is
out
man you've popped you in the mouth
winner of this round is gonna walk away
with a Kevin Smith pop from Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash if you've got
your cards finished throw them in the
air
Big Daddy Jimmy V Nate will collect them
once they're all collected we will let
you know what the real answers are five
seconds left before the round is over
ladies and gentlemen five four three two
one and we're done put your hands
together we finished round nine all
right Andy take us through man what rock
legend demanded Trump stop playing his
music at rallies this week that would be
Steven Tyler of Aerosmith father of lip
Tyler okay
number four to what American actress
recently withdrew from the UK's
Celebrity Big Brother would that be
Kirstie Alley it would be stormy Daniels
Daniels stormy Daniels she pulled out
for a change
Oh Andy working overtime getting
political I gotta do something over here
number three which kardashian-jenner
celebrated her birthday with a Barbie
theme party this week Andy that would be
Kendall Jenner Jenner did you get it he
brought a girl let's see number four
Beyonce is on the latest cover of Vogue
wearing what on her head Andy she's
wearing an enormous flower arrangement
large bouquet of flowers so we'll take
flowers bouquet yeah grass look grass
number five they added a new Oscar
category recently what is it that would
be best popular film best popular film
it's necessary there it is man we went
through the Funko pop pop culture
questions man what we got one winner
that's correct there's only one winner
send a representative up here because
they're gonna walk away with this pop
who is a dandy Andy become fish it's
stoners strike back donor strike back
[Applause]
look at Zack slow walking up here well
done my friend
give it up for me wanna pop ladies and
gentlemen all right dandy Andy we're
down to the last round round ten this is
the shirt off my background man the
winner of this round is gonna win this
fight and find Kevin Smith Jersey
the flash worn while I was making my
first I was in a second episode so
Jersey's been around for a while it's
very very large I think it's like a 4x
so it's yours for the taking you're
gonna win the shirt off my back if you
win this round I will sign it for you
all pens up phones down get ready to
answer these questions five is designed
by Professor Andrew mikkel first not a
real things Thank You number one
besides sleep you have to announce the
category oh oh that's right it's the
shirt off my back category so we always
have it back themed so explain that well
set your clocks back for weeks because
we're doing Back to the Future again
yeah we should just make it back to the
future every week oh here we go man
number one besides style what is it
about the DeLorean that makes it ideal
for time travel besides style what is it
about the DeLorean that makes it ideal
for Tom Joe Bob up number two Crispin
Glover 'he's father played a killer in
what James Bond movie Crispin glamour
had a famous actor father he didn't just
spring out of a central casting I did
not know that yes and his famous father
was in a number of movies and television
shows and famously played a killer in a
James Bond movie Wow
number three what is the name of the
little boy with the comic book on the
farm where Marty crashes the DeLorean in
1955
or something yes his dad mentions his
name what's the name of that little boy
a little boy on the farm or the DeLorean
crashes in 1955 that's tough I wouldn't
know that would be honest with you I
don't know the second one either I don't
even know the first one you'd [ __ ] me I
couldn't even win my own clothes because
well number four what is the name of the
first time traveler in the movie first
two time travel in the movie don't give
any clues away
there's careful be very careful folks
think number five the last question in
the round what show is Marty's dad a
huge fan of in 1955 what's the show that
Marty's dad is watching in 1955 there's
a very cool trivia bonus for that so I
can't wait to give the answer you answer
those questions folks and that means we
would be at an end of this round man
five very tough questions about a movie
I assumed I knew everything about but
apparently not man and II just stumped a
lot of us when you're done
hand in your cards just throw them up in
the air wave them like you just don't
care and Big Daddy Jimmy B and Nate will
collect them from you where'd you pull
all these from how hard you have to
think I actually watched the movie it's
fun it's a fun thing to do of course it
is what you notice this time around
speak while I'm [ __ ] change in my
Jersey there was a lot of obviously
these questions and I noticed how sweary
Michael J Fox is like the first time you
sees the DeLorean disappear into the
future by a minute he goes Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ just starts screaming Jesus
Christ
so yeah it's weird it's kind of a
there's funny things in there like that
and I saw I was looking for this in the
soda shop fight scene you can see the
original Marty McFly Eric Stoltz he
throws a punch from off-screen and you
see his face
are you serious what
what what what whoa we're about to have
extra questions yet we were just vamping
is that it we're done with the round
correct everybody hand in their cards
round ending in five four three two one
[ __ ] that rounds over put your hands
together we're finished all right ladies
and gentlemen this is the answer key and
you're gonna take us through it besides
style what is it about the DeLorean that
makes it ideal for time travel Andy the
professor says or
I mean Doc Brown says it is the
stainless steel body that lets the flux
capacitor do its job so we were looking
for stainless steel body one of the only
cars ever to be made with a stainless
steel body number two Crispin Glover z--
dad played a killer in what James Bond
movie I don't know this it was diamonds
are forever
there he is mr. Kidd and mr. wint the
couple that goes around murdering people
and after he drops his Cologne in the
trunk James Bond says it smells like a
taut and creature nice number three what
is the name a little boy with a comic
book on the farm where Marty crashes the
DeLorean that would be Sherman Peabody
his name is sure everybody body in honor
of Peabody and Sherman and the wayback
machine is adorable I never noticed that
only [ __ ] a little [ __ ] Bullwinkle
shut up all right here we go number four
what is the name of the first time
traveler in the movie I'm gonna say
Einstein Einstein the dog ladies and
gentlemen yes because that's what the
doc calls him I nee as well and then
number five what show is Marty's dad a
huge fan of in 1955 science fiction
theater it's a real show and do you know
who starred in science fiction theater
the actor's name I do know Michael Fox
just a little trivia fun for you did
they know that like that role the
Kennedy thing that's very cool all right
there was there was around is that the
winner this is the winner we've done all
the questions I mean
a winner ladies gentlemen there's one in
Andy's hand and somebody gonna walk away
with the shirt off my back who is
winning this gigantic jersey Andy well
thanks to science fiction theater it's
three walkies walk into a bar clean it
up man one of the good frame it do
something with it okay what we do now is
Gemma's look back over the previous 10
categories ten rounds and figure out two
more prizes the first prize is right
there first prize is what they call what
the wooden spoons the wooden spoon round
the wooden spoon round that means the
person Jimmy or the team who did the
absolute worst Big Daddy Jimmy be
animation the winner which is really the
loser how's that round is going to win
one of these fine Canadian beavers
ladies gentlemen we got a bunch of room
because we took their their Mountie
jackets off to put on our proxies and
yoga hosers so we've got a bunch of
these Canadian beavers so the winner of
the wooden spoon walks away with one of
them beavers oh [ __ ]
bear with buckteeth really so tell who
is it Andy who's the worst team in the
room well congratulations - meow yogi
meow yogi wins the wooden spoon all
right man that means the only winner
left Andy is the grand prize winner this
would be the team that won the most
rounds correct overall and that means
they walk away with an edge m'a
challenge coin china challenge coins
which we don't have we don't have any we
don't here we've got that hollow victory
really it really is but you'll you'll
walk away with something that says well
we know we'll know these guys the next
time we see him and we'll get him there
nickel next next time they come yes and
soon the metal coins are coming I would
imagine how long before the metal coins
come from Florida we're [ __ ]
soon we'll have the metal coins but
until then we've got the wooden coins
but today we don't even [ __ ] those so
today it's an imagined
coin ladies and gentlemen who wins this
week's edge of a pub quiz Ejim a
challenge coin Andy congratulations to
three wookies guys we'll give you
something that says that you're owed
something man so that you come back you
trade it in and [ __ ] y'all have a good
time ladies and gentlemen give it up for
the guy without whom there is no [ __ ]
quiz the man who pulled all the
questions together professor Andrew
McHale fish not a real professor and
that is the edge of a pop quiz for this
week I'm Kevin Smith and I'm Andy McHale
friend you have been educated man good
night everybody